selon vous pourquoi Nabila et Thomas ont
fait la une cette semaine une de quoi
d'un magazine potin
encore un bébé non non
tu peux pas faire plus court il déménage
en France non il revient pas oh mais non
la réponse selon le magazine Public
alors vous allez dire sur le magazine
Public le couple au bord de la rupture
ce serait donné un weekend pour se
laisser une dernière chance on voit le
titre de public avec de changer le
public le coup je leur ai posé ses
balises au Brésil pour s'offrir un
voyage pour se retrouver quelle chance
d'être triste quand ça va mal quoi
[Applaudissements]
pas de langue de bois j'avais besoin de
ce voyage hashtag détox du couple ça
veut dire quoi
de ce comment dire de ce de ce purifier
avec elle a le droit
c'est purifier que ton mari
ça veut dire que tu as besoin Magalie si
tu viens pour nous sortir des trucs de
presse Nord dit la vérité la vérité
et ce qu'on m'a dit ils sont tout va
très bien il y a aucun problème
simplement c'est vrai qu'il travaille
ensemble ils ont eu un deuxième enfant
cette année donc forcément tout ce que
ça implique c'est c'est important
voilà et ça c'est mieux non et voilà
c'est juste le genre de rumeur qui
entoure leur couple depuis des années ça
va super beau donc ils vont bien
sûr Nabilla elle est super maligne
va mal se dire que ça fait du bien
parfois d'être de respirer d'être en
forme oui
avec tout le monde prof de maths c'est
une preuve de maturité je trouve
exactement de travailler sur son couple
et de pas claquer la porte dès qu'il y a
un clou dans un caillou dans dans ma
grand-mère vous êtes toujours c'est
marrant les coups voilà dès que ça va
pas vous séparer c'est vrai c'est fou ça
et puis d'autre part je trouve qu'il y a
une très belle évolution je les trouve
incroyablement classe rapport aux
souvenirs que j'ai reçu des couples
c'était quand même pas cette image là et
là je les trouve mais vraiment il y a
quelque chose de gracieux
par mois ça est-ce que aujourd'hui c'est
plus c'est mon tournage j'imagine même
pour pour Nabilla alors Nabilla c'est
une icône voilà donc je peux pas je peux
pas moi moi à la place que j'ai je ne
peux pas aujourd'hui dévoiler vous
comprenez rien
concrètement si tu ne sers à rien dans
cette émission ça va être un souci
avec un souci
c'est comme si je te demandais combien
tu payes Benoît Dubois je vais pas te
dire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
stimuler les boulons tu sais que Benoît
il prend un PV il est flat il est en
transport du coup
et que forcément elle est à son niveau
d'icône
et puis elle est attention elle a ses
programmes avec Amazon enfin c'est c'est
la dernière alors on va se mettre direct
au clair c'est pas du chiffre
mais vas-y c'est de la menace quoi vas-y
direct